one of the easiest ways to break a
belief is be around people who are
making significantly more than you
because what you find out is that they
are made of the same thing as you same
flesh same bones same brain sometimes
you meet them and you're like how is
this guy doing it and rather than WR off
this guy's such an idiot think despite
him being an idiot he's still more
successful than me imagine if I used my
work ethic and my intelligence on the
same lessons that this guy obviously has
right and when I shifted my perspective
from that way I was able to start using
other people's successes to fuel me
rather than to make me feel bad